let's let's let's go to the first story
because we were gonna talk about like
climate change stuff - which which we
will get into this but the the lead
story is the UK is pissed off because
China's been engaged in this
disinformation campaign since the start
of this they've been lying to us it's
been getting worse and I had to wonder
like at what point do we consider that
an act of war yeah good so BuzzFeed
reported that Chinese trolls are going
online and they're sowing disinformation
which results in a slower response and
it actually results in people dying
civilians this is not like a military
thing so at what point do we say they're
actually killing our people and we do
something about it I honestly don't know
but in this whole like controversy
involving the UK government there you
know this circumstance they're actually
saying they think China's numbers are
fifteen to forty times worse so that
China might actually have like 45,000
dead why would people choose to like
believe this kind of stuff but then when
convenience yeah it's like they're
obviously not giving us the truth with
yet numbers then they're like oh well
but they say it's the u.s. now so let's
jump on that and run with that story
it's political experience so you get
some journalist who's trying to craft a
narrative they know what the story is
before they even looked anything up they
don't what they don't look up all these
information and then think themselves
like whoa here's what's happening they
say how do I do a story about you know
Boris Johnson of UK being bad oh I know
here's what here's a news story from
China and they say but China says this
like as if we take anything they say
serious right exactly so so I see this
story and I started wondering about like
what the limit would be to where we
actually say hey man you know like
you're getting people killed and this is
story from defense one from March 10th
where you have major adversaries of the
United States you know their media is
pushing bioweapon conspiracy theories I
believe what they say in this articles
that Iran is is the main culprit and
doing this so you have Chinese officials
going on Twitter
yeah claiming the US military spread
this in China officials are saying
officials yeah you're saying they are a
popular citizens a verified Twitter use
oh wow and Twitter does nothing that's
ridiculous yeah man so listen this is
going to damage our reputation around
the world yeah it's going to impede our
ability to get supplies and what point
no I think I feel like every story I'm
reading is people all these different
countries are like piss to China for
sending them bunk like Mouse mask yeah
but to read test its Europe it's not you
know Iran dude did I tell you about what
China was doing back in January no no no
siphoning away recent medical resources
from Australia Canada Canada and other
countries not I didn't hear that
so this was sending Sydney Sydney
Morning Herald and news.com a you in
Australia okay
a whistleblower came out and said that
around the time that China was telling
all of the world there was no problem no
human human transmission they were
advising their employees in foreign
countries to start buying up as much
medical supplies as possible like hazmat
suits masks PPE gear and shipping them
off to China as much as they could and
they did and Canada and Australia were
two countries that gave away a ton of
their medical gear and now we're all
panicked we can't get it and then when
masks were being made in China by
American companies China turned around
to Quebec so China knew and we have a
timeline that going back to like
December China had evidence there was
human to human transmission and this was
getting really bad
but then January 5th or something the
w-h-o was like 15 oh 15th they were like
China sighs there was playerbase China
says there's no human human transition
and preliminary tests and then they have
do you see that guy from who
yeah when I saw that timer off turns a
Skype off yeah what is up with that and
it's like it makes me feel like the
whu-oh is just a Chinese entity like
Japan I'm supposed to believe them Japan
apparently called them the Chinese
Health Organization like just straight
up called him out really the dude
so so for those aren't familiar right
there was a woman from Hong Kong
interviewing a guy from the World Health
Organization and she said I wanted to
ask you about Taiwan's response and the
guy just says nothing he stares blankly
and she's like Hello and he goes oh I
didn't I didn't hear you
and she also let's move on to a
different question oh she goes let me
ask you again no that's okay we'll take
another question she's like no I want to
ask you about Taiwan and then Boop
turns off Skype you know they call him
back and then he's and then when she
asked him again he calls it China
oh we've talked about China already all
over China they had a great response
know that no they haven't you know
they're lying about their numbers
they're cranking out the crematoriums
are running at
capacity according to numerous stories
yeah and it's it's and I think what like
China China screwed up China lied they
exploited it they're exploiting it now
their their disinformation is getting
people killed in our countries and every
step of the way they're doing this this
really annoying tactic of like whatever
we say they say it right back so when we
started seeing people question whether
or not this originated in a Chinese lab
yeah so there was a study out of and
this is this is China's fall it's not
done anything to with us there was a
study out of South China University
saying that some guy was doing
experiments was researching bat
coronavirus bright and then he had
gotten bitten or that he had you know
been peed on or something and so he self
quarantined and that may have been the
cause because this was like literally
across the street from the from the food
market I don't know what article I was
reading but I did read one I can't
verify it because I don't have it with
me but it's it's saying that it's not
man-made this is a biological from an
animal right that happened to be you
know transferred to human and then
exploded from there and we've known
about the possibility of this for a long
time
yeah it's happened before in smaller
numbers and weaker viruses sometimes you
in the lottery men it happens now I do
think it's hilarious and I don't mean
hilarious isn't like haha having a good
time I mean like eerily strange kind of
funny that it's like we had a meme a
meme going around of like 2020 we're
gonna have a pandemic whoo-hoo and
everyone's laughing and they're like
ahaha yeah and then it happened yeah
then it actually happens yeah well we
should actually read this bio weapon
thing yeah it's so I don't anything
about this yeah basically the reason I
bring this up is like they're throwing
extreme conspiracies back in our face
and what worries me is if we have this
disinformation that's getting people
killed
this right here is them accusing us of
an act of war
yeah so and what everyone I mean I heard
rumors for two months now that oh did
they do this on purpose is this a
biological attack like it's not like
this is a rumor that is just popping up
it's almost like yeah they heard I mean
I don't I don't see any senator or like
Trump didn't say like I think it's a
biological attack you know it's like
it's random people who are just beer see
if they're saying it well for them it's
that it's like their media right yeah
so it's actually let's let's read the
Schism context defense one says Chinese
authorities maintain that kovat 19
likely originated at a market in Wuhan
where people were selling bat meat but
Iranian Russian and Chinese propaganda
media outlets would like you to believe
without evidence I love that without
evidence that the emerging public health
crisis comes from us biological weapons
disinformation about the corona virus is
spreading as quickly as the outbreak
fuelled by Iranian Russian and Chinese
government backed campaigns blaming and
attacking the United States as the
source of the scourge one narrative all
three countries including China
highlight is the notion that the u.s. is
weaponizing the crisis for political
gain and thus worsening its spread
globally Rachael ternasky a project
manager for the foreign influence
election 2020 project with the Foreign
Policy Research Institute wrote
yesterday you know it's fine
it's true literally what I've heard is
true no no I totally disagree well you
mean they the Democrats weren't like
using this to try to sneak more stuff
into the bill that yeah but not globally
okay not globally like okay well I so I
guess the way I see when they say the US
is weaponizing it for political gain
well it sounds like we're singing it
spread globally I feel as a separate
statement to the first part is
weaponizing for political gain period I
definitely think that there is an
activist media contingent with with a
political overlap okay that are trying
to exploit this to hurt Trump and make
political gains no I mean you look at
Joe Biden saying it was you know phobic
to close the borders and it's like every
country on the planet did this dude
we're talking about yeah but what I see
from this is basically what I've said
about China we know they're lying we
know they're doing they're engaging in
disinformation campaigns it's getting
people killed and they're doing it for
political gain they're sending bunk
equipment to you know Italy and Spain
Netherlands
I mean China's claiming that those
weren't like I want to say fda-approved
but they're obvious but that's it's a
company that isn't approved by like the
government so supposedly the
government's issued stuff is okay do you
know how piracy worked back in the day
in the colonial area colonial era I'm
not sure I don't know let's say you know
your France got a bunch of boats full of
spices delicious delicious spices sure
when all of a sudden another ship comes
up privateer with you know black black
sails or whatever whatever they did and
they start firing on you and you fight
but you win
and so you board the privateer and it
turns out all the dudes English and
you're like these English em effers man
yeah so when you go to England they go
oh it's a privateer oh it's it's if
they're criminals we don't we all we
have nothing to do with this and then
the next day they go to another
privateer and say here's your here's
your mission go disrupt the French
supply lines and if you get caught we
just have out yeah so what we see with
China and other countries today is
something very similar where you'll see
private criminals yeah and private
companies and China will be alike when
we catch these people we'll bring them
to justice we are so sorry they sold you
faulty equipment right and then they go
back home and say good job yeah okay how
do you think that's what's going on I
mean maybe it could be that people are
exploiting the the crisis in there and
they're you know selling garbage for
quick a quick walk you know I mean like
yeah if you could mass-produce trash and
sell it for you know ten bucks per trash
these people do it and it doesn't seem
like China cares because they're
exploiting foreign interests not
national interests you don't think
that's what's happening here
do you think that this is them going all
right go spread this information yeah
but if you get caught we're just gonna
be like you're no no this is coming from
like their official oh no you said
that's official that's crazy we're
saying the Iranian government also and
the Russian government well the
government all official people so it
look the government's are playing it up
like no no we are not claiming it like
they mentioned China is saying it was
from the bat but then China Chinese
media goes but what if so the media news
flash the media everywhere pretty much
lies mostly yeah but their their media
is is an arm of the communist regime
yeah that's true good in the USA much
worse I'd be willing to bet based on the
title of this video me like criticizing
these foreign countries they're gonna
claim I was pushing the conspiracy
because that's what our media does true
like they carry water for China man they
love it they love they love the the
Communist teat all the sweet milk that
comes along with it dude
Marco so Marco Rubio
marco rubio's yeah he tweeted something
like journalists are gleefully you know
celebrating or enjoying the the damage
or whatever some like that I don't want
to misquote him but it was it was you
know a bunch of journalists were like
how dare you no one takes pleasure in
any of this so then he posted a bunch of
tweets where it was like a bunch of
stories rebel yeah right and like making
snarky political jokes about it and
stuff yeah so you know what man the
media in this country is free and they
do this and I think you know the bigger
question I have about all of this is at
what point are we gonna see a crackdown
on the First Amendment because guess
what we're already seeing a crackdown on
we already see we're already seeing a
crackdown on most of the First Amendment
freedom of religion and the right to
peaceably assemble both completely
infringed upon right now gone yeah you
can't gather in groups of more than two
in some places how does that make sense
and they're saying you can't go to
places of worship and they're actually
you know they're calling out people who
are engaging in worship and it's like
the government can't stop you the
argument is well quarantine that is that
a good enough argument it's tough right
yeah it's a tough question you know I
don't know how to answer it really
because you know I I believe every whoa
we're both libertarians like I want
everyone to do what they want to do but
then at the same time I don't I don't
want stupid Google going out and
gathering and spreading it around like
that story we read or yo that we're
going to later on it's a great conundrum
man yeah that's right so so you know
this this whole thing is interesting and
I think we should actually touch a
little bit upon like the possibility of
war before we get into like you know
because it's it's it's the war if we go
if we get if we enter any kind of war
then you'll see your your civil
liberties gone right yeah so do you
think this is why they started talking
about the draft last week what they do
they talk about the draft all the time
but right but maybe the middle of a
pandemic
why isn't a man mentioning the women can
do other job why are they talking about
all right now yeah yep it's kind of a
interesting time I mean this has been
this this this international conflict
has been brewing for a long time true
and me and many other journalists who
cover
conflict have been kind of I don't
honestly waiting for it but speculating
as to when we would actually see
full-scale warfare apparently we had
World War three with Iraq and Iran
already so this would be in fact world
war four how would that is the entire
world included in that but it's a joke
okay yeah you know like Iran fire drag
and then you know I'm sorry no whoever
calls it World War three you're wrong
but there's uh okay so you know there's
been there's been a lot of speculation
about Syria the Qatar Turkey pipeline
Gazprom natural gas in Europe the
conflict we have and the proxy wars
they've all been going on for decades
it's all part of the same conference
never ended yeah but at certain point
you know the spark hits we were sitting
on a powder keg and then the coronavirus
happened you know now maybe it's a bio
weapon I don't think so I think it's
just these things happen but is it gonna
be a spark that lights the fuse or is it
gonna be like an acid that just melts
away the barrel so nothing happens do
you know what I mean it's like I feel
like he could go either way I don't know
man so China's claiming they have 2500
dead and they're like no new cases and
we're like on the downturn and people
are uncritically showing their numbers
it was a really funny thing I saw on
Twitter where this guy has a graph where
he's like I took all of the data on
coronavirus and you can track different
countries and then there was a
frequently asked question why isn't
China on this graph and he said because
their numbers are fake yeah okay so
we've seen locals saying the
crematoriums crematoriums have been
running full-speed non-stop in China and
people have been that was originally a
conspiracy theory the original
conspiracy theory was that people could
see satellite images of crematoriums
going nuts right and that all the
fact-checking agencies were like no no
no it's not true it's medical supplies
now a bunch of mainstream outlets are
like we have some serious questions
about the number of urns being delivered
yeah
because apparently like five thousand
got delivered in like one period or
something I don't I don't how long a
certain period is but they said over the
next 12 days we're gonna be delivering
more urns and people are like so that's
what like forty-five to fifty thousand
urns yeah why what right two thousand
deaths two 2,500 deaths
yeah because empty everybody gets an
empty okay just in case we're just you
know restocking up
or like those videos we saw people are
collapsing in the street and it's really
really bad
so so so here's the bigger question you
you say could it be like an acid just
dissolving the powder keg and just
fizzles away I don't know man if the
amount of deaths are seriously that
crazy in China we now have you know
17,000 combined in Spain and Italy
it's like 11,000 in Italy if the numbers
really are that high in this short of a
timespan then at what point do they
become desperate people are starting you
know countries are now hoarding food
yeah so we're you know one of the first
things that needs to happen is hard
dividing lines so people know who's
who's you know who's fighting who yeah
that's a good point we've talked a lot
about like the possibility of a civil
war in the u.s. and one of the things
that makes it less likely is that
there's not going to be a clear
delineation between affections and so
it's really difficult to fight if you go
outside you're like here's a guy okay
he's wearing a muse shirt are you on my
side yeah I have no idea versus if
people are like wearing clear you know
patches or or in a certain area and you
walk into there and say hey you what are
you doing you know you're on this
territory I mean y'all suit it up so I
guess I guess Mike my question is like
for this for this opening segment is
like at what point do we say this is war
is it gonna be like a shot heard around
the world moment because look man well
what would that be like I I can't
picture any sort of warfare where anyone
gets out of this you know on top you
know of course like China claims if
their numbers are wrong which everyone's
assuming they're wrong lies yeah they're
then they're not in very good shape
we're not in very good shape no one's in
very good shape and if you know if we go
to war that means you know we would want
to supply them with food and whatever to
keep but the slope the supply lines are
already kind of oh yeah they're getting
in a rut you know in some areas I'm
already hearing that people can't get
supplies anymore yeah so it's
interesting because when you're on
Twitter you're like in one place where
you can see everyone talking then you
got to realize people are all over the
world so I saw one person tweeting about
how there's no you know like there's
there's certain certain supplies are
completely drain
my area and we can't get him anywhere we
can't even order him you know and so
like we went to the store the other day
to like you know just get get food stuff
and we're like seemed fine oh they had
time normal had a full pallet of 25
pound bags of flour yeah I didn't know
eggs was the one thing that was gone
right no their decks but it was less
it's Sam's right Walmart Walmart Walmart
was missing a ton of stuff right that
makes sense though because Sands is like
you know not that much though right yeah
as I expected to see
yeah they had milk and eggs were gone
that was it yeah so and your perishable
which well I guess you couldn't keep him
there his ways there were some things
but for the most part it was like it
seemed like there's a little bit less of
most things but most things were there
yeah but in some areas they are getting
hit so anyway I guess I don't know man
I think if China gets strained and they
can that you know the factories are shut
down if they can't produce food if we
can over produce food then I don't think
we have anything anything really to
worry about I don't think anyone's gonna
want to fight yeah you know they're
gonna try and secure their own
circumstances of their own situations
but if if if somebody died in the u.s.
because of disinformation and they did
what do we say to their family like so
so we have what I think around 2000 just
over just over 2000 people have died so
far in the US now some people want to
blame Trump I don't think that's fair
I think to a certain point you can
criticize the president you can
criticize Bill DeBlasio a lot more
because New York is the hardest hit New
York City is the hardest place and Cuomo
gets some of the criticism but come on
the fault is really on China for lying
to us yeah if they came out right away
and said look preliminary data shows
human human transmission
it could be a false alarm but seriously
get ready for this everybody locked down
let's do this yep you know they're out
there waiting it you know they're
exploiting it they they meet well for
one they immediately started having
their employees in other countries
siphon away emergency medical gear and
send it to China and so they did it in a
legal way they did it through the free
market which leads to a serious you know
conundrum I see on the internet where
they're like all they did was buy up as
much as they could through free market
practice yeah and my response is by
lying to us lying to the World Health
Organization so that no one understood
how
it was and then a lot of people are like
oh that's really it's really cool that
we're helping China with their medical
gear because you know they're facing a
shortage and now that we've got a
hundred and twenty thousand or so people
in the US we're like we need medical
gear and it's why that that's what
that's to me is why it's so annoying
when people are like Trump has fumbled
this across the board and it's like look
man
well people feel better when they play
when they have someone to blame blame
China come on
good point yeah but the media is too
busy carrying water for them saying it's
racist if you if you blame China yeah
yeah the Communist Party of China is not
a race it is an authoritarian
organization of some sort yeah that's a
good point yeah so so so anyway here's
here's here's the main point we can move
on to another subject but I'm just to
the people who have whose families have
lost their lives you know who have lost
loved one loved ones if they want
answers you know are they gonna ignore
this or do we need to tell them like
China lied and the people you cared
about died and there's there anything is
gonna come from it and and if we do want
something come from it what if China
says fu do we just say okay that's
that's cool we're not gonna do anything
you're good or does somebody say nah and
then you know I think I think really in
order for war to break out you need some
kind of hard desperation or ideological
zealotry
right china would have to be like we are
seizing the South China Sea period
full-on military blockade and we shoot
down any plan any ship that comes into
that space and then if the US says we're
going to you know fly in international
waters and then you know cuz China
already lasered a plane cover last month
or whatever so we've been dangerously
close I don't want to act like I think
it's guaranteed but I've had people you
know who cover this stuff and and who
have you know worked in military stuff
being like dude it's it's getting worse
than it's ever been especially with no
pandemic with a lot with the loss of you
know food stores food stores hoarding
and then you have these media companies
or I should say companies but state-run
propaganda yeah trying to convince their
populations we did this to them yeah
there's this this article I read about
like the escalation of the blame game
between China and America basically
because once Trump went on and said the
Chinese virus it was kind of
pointing a big finger at China saying
you're to blame and it's not necessarily
the Chinese citizens you know it is the
CCP who was like we're not saying
anything to anybody you know and that's
why CCP virus is better right exactly
Jin Pen Clegg makes a lot more sense but
then now they're doing this because it's
what how are you gonna go further up
from it's not our fault and like we're
it's not the Chinese virus bully you're
the one who put it there then yeah but
like that camp a bioweapon claim is so
much like more egregious absolutely I
agree it's look if we've if we've got a
you know a bunch of random people on the
internet claiming that it was a Chinese
bioweapon like come on of course it's
like people gonna go there and say
whatever they want yeah
if state-run media organizations or
state sanctioned or controlled media
organizations are telling their citizens
the United States what engineered a bio
weapon to go after them yeah yeah
they're gonna take they're gonna be
alike we're they're gonna be rallied
right there so this is what people you
know - you know the false flag is mm-hmm
so this is what people basically it's
kind of like a false flag convince your
people that you're under attack you know
a false flag would be they attack
themselves and then blame it on someone
else using flying the a false flag right
right but but it's similar in that they
need to get all of their people on board
with full-on conflict with us not that
some of these countries actually need
that but Russia kind of does because the
Russian people in the American people
for the most part don't they absolutely
do not hate each other
you know what this almost feels like
remember we were talking about those
videos that were emerging we weren't we
weren't able to show them to you guys
because we can't really confirm them but
which I know seeing videos out of China
of almost like Civil War like people
were fighting and like being locked away
and like oh yeah joining their own
police force and fighting others well
that video is public everyone seen it
that's imported yeah so on they're
flipping a police view I mean this
almost seems like they're trying to
convince their own citizens and it has
almost nothing to do with us I mean
obviously it does because we're the main
target here but it's like if people are
actually rising up against the CCP in
China that we won't know we're not gonna
know anything about that but it actually
happened which it looks like that's
caught that could be happening we have
we won't ever know about it until years
from now you know finally the CCP will
get overthrown and people will be like
oh yeah remember back
when the coronavirus hit yeah we started
at that point and we were we've had a
civil war and and and always look at it
how does China stop that from happening
it was America
yeah let's let's you know don't worry it
wasn't us it was America they did it
it's like and we're here to protect you
right you must trust us
yeah that's American czar doing that's
what it sounds like to me yeah it's like
they're really because it's it's stupid
that gets it I think it was a Chinese
doctor that that confirmed that no no
that not that blew the whistle but
confirmed that it was an animal like
natural anyway of course and then like
we confirmed it and like a bunch of
doctors around the globe were like yeah
it's a natural thing right it's not like
it was a bioweapon which now they're
pushing you know and so it's kind of
convenient in the time where I saw those
last week where people were fighting
yeah I don't know and here and you know
we can we can kind of wrap up on this
point cuz I think you kind of nailed it
but yeah when the people of China flip
over a police you know vehicle these are
people who get arrested and tortured for
saying naughty words yeah for saying I
think I think you're stupid policeman
yep and then it gets eaten they say
sorry right say you say sorry 20 times
and they're and they're sitting there
like clearly all messed up I mean dude
took the riot shield and was beating the
other cop with it yeah man you know so
they need to get a handle on things
surprise they do this stuff the UK is
furious about it thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you